este año el balance es ambivalente por
un lado tenemos en nuestra región 58
millones de mujeres viviendo en zonas
rurales y una parte importante de ellas
juega un rol fundamental en la
producción y abastecimiento de alimentos
sin embargo 6 millones según pronósticos
de las naciones unidas en la región
pueden caer en pobreza extrema a raíz de
la pandemia se ha recrudecido situación
es de fundamental atención en toda la
región como por ejemplo la inseguridad
alimentaria y nutricional que tiene una
relación directa como ustedes saben con
la salud de las mujeres y pues 37 países
y territorios de la región han cerrado
sus escuelas lo que ha implicado que al
menos 113 millones de niños y de niñas
en toda la américa latina estén
necesitando de 24 horas diarias de
atención eso supone una sobrecarga de
trabajo de las mujeres quienes ya tienen
un triple
en sus hogares en también sus chacras en
sus tierras produciendo los alimentos
que se necesitan para que lleguen a las
ciudades las mujeres no han parado en el
campo y eso ha evitado en una crisis
sanitaria como la que estamos viviendo
en este momento se pudiera convertir en
una crisis alimentaria sí y valorar ese
rol es fundamental fundamental por eso
para nosotros es clave el trabajo que
estamos realizando en el marco de la
campaña mujeres reales mujeres con
derechos señora brito independiente de
la coyuntura de la pandemia de kobe 19
qué papel debería tener entonces en el
escenario más deseado la mujer rural
lo principal es garantizar sus derechos
las mujeres tienen un rol transformador
en nuestras comunidades son ellas las
guardianas de las semillas las
guardianas de la tierra las guardianas
de la biodiversidad en nuestros países y
es fundamental que los países los
gobiernos todos los sectores de las
economías y de la vida social te puedan
apoyar en un nivel multisectorial la
situación de las mujeres es clave que en
este momento podamos promover la
autonomía económica de las mujeres de
las indígenas y de las afrodescendientes
mediante el desarrollo en regulaciones y
de políticas públicas por supuesto de
inversión pública para la atención a la
situación que están viviendo en este
momento señora brito muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en france 24 de
haber conversado con nosotros sobre este
tema